c'est fort
fin
bonjour à tous je suis ses coûts et les
tec dans les épisodes précédents
nous avons déjà expliqué ce que font les
avocats et les procureurs
aujourd'hui nous allons parler des
magistrats alors c'est quoi au magistrat
le magistrat est injuste qui rompt la
justice en faisant respecter les textes
de loi c'est un métier qui est
extrêmement difficile d'accès il
commande vient ton magistrats pour
devenir magistrat il faut avoir au
minimum un bac +4 ou droit obtenir le
concours de l'école nationale de la
magistrature et faire tromper en mois de
scolarité qui commence par une
prestation de serment par les futurs
magistrats
le magistrat aura un statut de
fonctionnaire familière nous on l'a
parents un juge
quelles sont les missions des magistrats
il y à une distinction entre le
magistrat du siège et le magistrat du
parquet le magistrat du siège fait
appliquer la loi
il est garant du bon déroulement des
procès étudie le dossier héron un
jugement conforme au droit notamment
après avoir écouté les accusés et les
accusateurs ainsi que les arguments de
leurs avocats il peut fixer des
sanctions et des peines et ordonné des
dommages et intérêts ces fonctions varie
selon sa spécialisation qui peut-être
juge d'instance juge des enfants juge de
l'application des peines juge des
affaires familiales et cetera
le magistrat du parquet doit quant à lui
défendre l'intérêt public
les intérêts de la société et veiller au
respect de l'ordre public il peut être
substitut procureur ou avocat général il
dirige les enquêtes de police et décide
des suites à donner en cas d'infraction
et s'assure aussi que les peines
prononcées sont bien exécutées il
propose une peine que le magistrat du
siège décidera ou non de prononcer les
magistrats sont des agents publics qui
ont un statut particulier il
peuvent pas être destitués de leurs
postes l'idée placée contre leur gré à
l'audience ils sont assis pour les après
la magistrature assise
le parquet est quant à lui qualifié de
magistrature debout
il est placé sous l'autorité du garde
des sceaux comme il s'agit de postes à
grande responsabilité
le magistrat prend sa décision finale
entouré de nombreux professionnels comme
des avocats des huissiers des greffiers
des officiers et agents de police des
experts et travailleurs sociaux des
médecins des psychologues et caetera et
quelles sont les compétences requises
pour être un bon magistrat
un magistrat doit être à la fois que les
roues et juste impartiale et aller coûte
au quotidien il est à la recherche de la
vérité
la décision finale du magistrat peut
avoir parfois de lourdes conséquences
sur la vie des gens et à la réunion où
est ce qu'on peut trouver des magistrats
à la réunion où se trouvaient les
magistrats au tribunal de grande
instance à saint denis et à saint pierre
mais aussi au tribunal d'instance de
saint paul et de saint benoît j'espère
que vous avez bien compris ce qu'est un
magistrat à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode